[Musique]
lors de votre journal de l'afrique soit
il est bienvenu dans cette édition à la
une la can 10 le bilan de la soirée vous
ce mardi soir à bafoussam qualifié sur
le fil pour les huitièmes le sénégal n'a
pas franchement brillé face au malawi la
guinée décevante aussi face au zimbabwe
une vingtaine de communes placées en
vigilance rouge à tananarive à
madagascar de très fortes pluies sont
tombées sur la capitale et et aux
alentours dix personnes au moins ont
perdu la vie elle les secours sont
toujours à pied d'oeuvre
et puis des barricades érigées à la hâte
nouvelle démonstration de force dans les
rues de khartoum et sa périphérie malgré
les risques encourus les civils restent
mobilisés face à la répression sans
limite de l'armée
la coupe d'afrique des nations a d'abord
on ouvre ce journal avec les derniers
résultats de ce mardi soir qualifié pour
les huitièmes de finale le sénégal n'a
pas brillé face au malawi 0 partout elle
met les hommes d'ali ou 6 et termine en
tête du groupe b et c'est bien là
l'essentiel
aux yeux de sadio magnon l'écoutent
c'est l'essentiel de se qualifier vous
savez comme je les dis
ça fait je sois disant suis dans cette
sélection et je pense que
que ce soit les qualifications où les
matches de poule de la coupe d'afrique
on a toujours cartonné
et c'est un aspect plus le cas et on
sait que
c'est pas du tout facile maintenant ce
que j'ai à vous dire est que soyez
patients on est tous conscients de ce
qui se passe en ce moment et je pense
que c'est pas ça ne plaît pas non plus
on voulait plutôt gagné 3,4 euros voire
plus mais bon si ça n'est pas le cas
on va essayer de prendre on va essayer
de faire comme ça et on a un match
maintenant on va essayer d'aller sur
lequel repose et préparer à les
huitièmes de finale
et bien sûr au nez on est là pour ça on
est conscient donc on va être dans votre
là on va la tenter de se recentrer les
lions de la teranga resteront donc à à
bafoussam avant une prochaine rencontre
mardi prochain et cédric ferreira
revient lui sur le match décevant de ce
soir assister encore à une nouvelle
prestation décevante du sénégal favoris
pour la victoire finale dans cette coupe
d'afrique des nations pour tant sur le
plan comptable c'est du quasi parfait
puisque sénégal est qualifié pour les
huitièmes de finale et en plus en
terminant à la première place de ce
groupe b ce qui signifie que les
sénégalais ont normalement sur le papier
un adversaire abordable lors de ces
huitièmes de finale mais c'est vrai que
les lions ont été franchement bousculé
par le malawi l'une des équipes les plus
faibles de cette coupe d'afrique des
nations sur le papier le malawi qui
continue de surprendre et malgré une
domination sénégalaise en première
période c'est bien les malawites qui
avaient été les plus dangereux avec une
chaussée chevauchée fantastique de gabat
digne ou mango le meilleur joueur du
malawi qui a bien failli marquer un but
très spectaculaire et puis en deuxième
période les sénégalais se sont procuré
plus d'occasions ils ont été plus
agressifs
jusqu'à cette fameuse 74ème minute où
tout le sénégal a retenu son souffle le
moment où l'arbitré signe un penalty en
faveur du malawi puis il est allé
consulter le vidéo arbitrage
est revenu donc sur sa décision penalty
annulé on en est donc rester à ce score
nul de 0 à 0 entre le sénégal et le
malawi mais c'est vrai que on reste sur
notre faim avec la prestation
sénégalaise pourtant pour ce match a lui
aussi s'ils avaient récupéré quasiment
tous ses joueurs il avait aligné la
meilleure équipe possible mais dans le
jeu bien on a pas vu vraiment
d'amélioration par rapport aux deux
précédents matches pour le sénégal
rendez vous toujours ici à bafoussam
mardi prochain la guinée elle et jouera
son 8e de finale un jour plus tôt
également ici à bafoussam à la guinée
que vous évoquez à l'instant cédric qui
affrontait tout à l'heure le zimbabwe en
match arbitré pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de la can par une femme on va
la nommer elle s'appelle salima radia
mou kasanga et les rwandaises c'était
même un quatuor féminin qui a dirigé
cette rencontre avec les arbitres
assistante la camerounaise karine à
thème à bong la marocaine à fatiha gm
ont mis aux commandes de l'arbitrage
vidéo une autre marocaine bouchra car
bouby et vous l'avez dit nabias larbitre
central c'était la rwandaise salima
radia mot candanga 35 ans elle avait
déjà écrit l'histoire puisque c'était la
première arbitres la première femme à
avoir été quatrième arbitre lors d'un
match de coupe d'afrique des nations
c'était il ya quelques jours lorsque la
guinée à affronter le malawi l'arbitré
rwandaise dispose d'une solide
expérience allait connue en afrique
depuis 2012 l arbitre des matchs sur le
continent africain elle avait officié
aussi lors de la coupe du monde féminine
en 2019 qui avait eu en france alors à
la tête de ce mba bouée guinée bien elle
a parfaitement rempli sa mission elle va
peut-être officiers de nouveau dans
cette coupe d'afrique des nations
puisqu'elle a elle a convaincu mais
surtout c'est le message qui est envoyé
par la confédération africaine de
football un message fort qui va
peut-être maintenant inspirer d'autres
jeunes femmes à se diriger vers la voie
de l'arbitrage et peut-être un jour à
leur tour officier dans une coupe
d'afrique des nations en tout cas là
c'est une nouvelle étape qui a été
franchie
dans cette coupe d'afrique des nations
avec maintenant des femmes qui officie
au plus haut niveau
la guinée qui s'est incliné face au
zimbabwe de buzeins et si le syli
poursuit laventure a convaincu les
supporters ne sont pas satisfaits de la
performance de ce mardi soir il
réagissait au micro de malik tchéquie t
on les écoute
c'était très bon le pis c'est de prendre
des cartons aussi bête que ça
ça fait aussi mal nous avions peur de ça
parce qu'on est qualifié mais prendre
aussi des cartons qui peut plier des
gros besoins des matches c'est aussi
énervant je m'attendais plus à une
victoire et une défaite
et j'espère qu'ils vont ou même
apprendre de leurs ébats de l'avant
parce que je sais bien que la guinée a
quelque chose à gagner dans cette salle
sachez que le capitaine de l'équipe
annabie keita est suspendu pour les
huitièmes 1 2 finale du côté du groupe c
maroc défier le gabon de but partout les
lions de l'atlas s'offre sept jours de
préparation avant une prochaine
rencontre mardi prochain à noter aussi
l'exploit des comores contrôle banal
comores qui disputaient leur première
can 3 buts à 2 pour les comores
voilà pour la can en reste de
l'actualité sur le continent je vous en
parlais dans les titres piégé par les
hommes en 10 personnes ont péri ce mardi
à à tananarive à madagascar en déluge de
pluie s'est abattue sur la capitale à
des centaines de maisons ont été
emportées par les flots la population
déjà éprouvée doit faire face dans les
prochains jours à de très fortes
précipitations
après des chutes de pluies diluviennes
les habitants de tananarive se réveille
avec de l'eau jusqu'aux genoux surpris
en pleine nuit par le déluge ils ne
peuvent que constater les dégâts paix à
leurs fins en it flow est entré et nous
ne savons pas comment l'évacuer de la
maison
on a mis les enfants sur le lit
superposé et on essaie de sauver ce
qu'on peut de nos affaires
les inondations ont entraîné des
glissements de terrain faisant au moins
10 morts et des centaines de sinistrés
et selon le ministère de l'intérieur le
pire reste à venir avec des
précipitations similaire attendu sur
tout le mois de janvier la mairie de
tananarive dit avoir ouvert un centre
d'hébergement pour accueillir les
familles ayant perdu leur logement
nous avons préparé les premiers sites
pour accueillir les sinistrés
la municipalité va les prendre en charge
on appelle tous les sinistrés à quitter
leur maison et à venir dans ces centres
pays au climat tropical madagascar est
régulièrement frappée par des typhons et
des cyclones pendant la saison des
pluies les intempéries dont l'impact est
amplifié par le dérèglement climatique
mais aussi par l'extrême pauvreté de
nombreux malgaches vivent dans des
logements de fortune souvent mal équipé
pour faire face aux fortes chutes de
pluie
les tirs à balles réelles ne les effraie
presque plus des hommes et des femmes
ont investi ce mardi encore les rues de
khartoum et et sa périphérie elle des
civils mobilisés pour dénoncer ce qu'ils
considèrent comme un massacre des civils
ont été tués ce lundi sept personnes au
moins des manifestants hostiles au
pouvoir en place les précisions de mme
hayat aguets
des barricades de fortune soigneusement
gardés et entretenus par les anti
putschistes elle n'arrête pas grand
chose mais symbolise les deux jours de
désobéissance civile lancée par les
opposants au coup d'état du 25 octobre
nous donne de la revoit toutes les rues
ont été barricadés et nous sommes en
grève du travail comme l'ont demandé les
révolutionnaires un sauvage une
mobilisation décidée en réaction à ce
que les activistes appelle déjà le
massacre du 17 janvier
ce lundi les forces de l'ordre
soudanaise pour sorti leurs armes
lourdes face aux manifestants qui
réclamaient le départ du pouvoir des
militaires au moins sept personnes ont
perdu la vie
nous sommes descendus dans la rue pour
exprimer pacifiquement notre opinion
mais les forces militaires ont fait
usage de balles réelles de gaz
lacrymogènes et de grenades
assourdissantes
nous appelons tout le peuple soudanais à
bloquer toutes les rues jusqu'à la chute
des putschistes ap la forêt par un
kabyle l'armée nie avoir tiré sur la
foule le leader dé facto du pays le
général albert and as premier les
résultats d'une commission denquête sous
quelques jours tout en validant la
création d'une force spéciale
antiterroriste pour lutter contre le
chaos qu'il attribue aux manifestants
dans ce pays sans parlement ni
gouvernement élu c'est la communauté
internationale qui espère encore relancé
la transition vers la démocratie
deux émissaires américains vous
rencontrez les forces de l'ordre à
khartoum pour leur demander de mettre
fin à la violence contre les
manifestants
sous embargo bamako tentent de
contourner les sanctions imposées par la
cédéao l'accompagné irin sky mal et
assurera une nouvelle liaison avec la
guinée voisine vers une alliance de
circonstance donc puisque conakry est
elle même suspendu l'organisation
régionale depuis le coup d'état
militaire de septembre dernier le
colonel keïta a également dépêché une
importante délégation ministérielle à
nouakchott reçu vous le voyez par le
président ahmadou ould ghazouani et
précisant que la mauritanie elle n'est
pas membre de la communauté des états
d'afrique de l'ouest
au tchad l'armée fait un pas de plus
vers la réconciliation une vingtaine de
rebelles et d'opposante été libérés
prison une amnistie avait été votée en
décembre dernier
296 personnes au total doivent en
bénéficier le jeune général au pouvoir
mahamat idriss déby espère maintenant
établir à un dialogue inclusif avant des
élections présidentielle et législatives
fixées au 15 février prochain
amazon à la conquête du continent le
géant du e-commerce veut bâtir les
locaux de son premier siège africain au
cap en afrique du sud est mais le site
convoité est une terre sacrée un lieu
ancestrale que compte bien défendre les
peuples autochtones charlie sitbon nous
en dit plus
situé près d'une zone industrielle du
cap le projet river club semblait comme
un lieu idéal pour implanter le siège
d'amazon pour le continent africain
c'était sans compter sur une série de
controverses selon des activistes pour
l'environnement ce terrain est inondable
cette terre a aussi une valeur
mémorielle c'est ici qu'il y a cinq
cents ans les premières nations
indigènes repousse les colons portugais
des années plus tard les indigènes
perdre sur ce même terrain une bataille
face aux hollandais ces derniers lancent
alors leur conquête coloniale
c'est le combat patrimoniale le plus
important que nous ayons en tant que sud
africain en effet si nous ne pouvons pas
prendre position sur ce que nous
considérons comme important dans nos
vies et sur les principes pour lesquels
nos ancêtres se sont toujours battus ce
sera moralement très difficile à
accepter
mais tous les indigènes ne sont pas
d'accord le projet comprend des
résidences des commerces des entreprises
et la création de 19 mille emplois le
développeur immobilier promet aussi de
construire un lieu de mémoire pour les
indigènes et une campagne pour défaire
tout cela et nous appelons ce qui
l'amène à ne pas le faire venez plutôt
vous asseoir avec le collectif des
premières nations pour discuter de vos
préoccupations soutien et opposants au
projet se retrouveront devant la haute
cour du cap qui devra trancher
c'est la fin de votre journal de
l'afrique reste avec nous sur france 24
la formation continue
[Musique]
du grand nord canadien jusqu'à ushuaia
toute l'actualité politique économique
culturel et social du continent
américain
car amériques présentée par elisabetta
là à regarder sur france 24 et france 24
points comme
pour ne plus laisser la buée sur vos
lunettes vous gâcher la vue regardez la
météo avec le kit anti buée harris
efficace même avec un masque
[Musique]